well I am the last man who did taxation
and interest rates none by my will I had
failed to persuade John Major's have an
independent Bank of England but I raise
rents and I put them down sometimes it
makes me think about what would I do if
I was still attending monetary policy
committee meetings and what would I do
if it was still my decision I would have
put up rates by a quarter percent they
have about two or three months ago and
I'd be ready to do it again but probably
not this year but my only next year I
mean anxiously looking at the data as
you get it I'd be expecting that the
next moves going to be up again I would
not be expecting that the next moves
going to be down but nobody's sure they
of course everybody realizes now I have
no involvement with any of these things
anymore you mentioned asset purchases by
the bank as well quantitative easing in
the jog and is it time for the banks to
start thinking about unwinding some of
these purchases in the way that the US
Federal Reserve is well not yet no I
think the economy is too weak for that
and you might give up and the boost to
inflation the sooner we can start
getting back in normality the better but
we just better see how we get on that
normally you know you'd refrain from
tightening policy when the economy's in
a weak ish commandeered position on this
occasion of the extra reasons as the
risk there's the inflation risk of
another devaluation III think there was
also risks we'd have another devaluation
make people poorer again by putting
inflation up higher I think to show
you're ready to put up interest rates
protects a bit against that and then all
this extraordinary borrowing that's
going on that you've got to stop so I
wouldn't do any more this year I came to
ask you what I would do I would expect
that I'd be raising it again trying to
persuade the committee to raise it again
in beginning of next year very striking
we've had the eurozone third quarter GDP
data this week the eurozone now I'm
stripping the UK's GDP growth as France
even doing so quite strikingly
are you concerned about the pace of
brexit talks and the kind of impact
that's having on economic activity here
I mean the bank clearly is well the
eurozone growth is very good news
because it's our major
kid so we do need something speaking for
us so that that is and I hope it's
continued I when I meet European
politicians I felt not to get
overexcited and start giving me the
usual propaganda the eurozone is going
through a good patch about you know and
it could sustain this I hope so it's
very good news for Britain when they do
because their major market our problem
and a British problem is the brexit
talks are completely stalled and they
will remain stalled until the British
government have agreed with each other
on a policy of what they really want to
pursue and that is having a very adverse
effect on our economy and others you
know the global effect the economy is
affected by all this uncertainty about
what exactly the British are going to do
when they pull out of their present
relationship with the rules-based system
the world's run by looking ahead to the
budget which is now just three weeks
away anything that you would be looking
to do particularly if you were still in
number 11 are we looking to try to keep
the country on track to try to avoid
going for more borrowing and debt than
we already have which is too much trying
to do what I can to stimulate the
development of a modern new economy and
just as the governor of the Bank of
England has demonstrated that he has a
duty to pursue grown-up policies
I'm sure the chance of his Cheka Philip
Allen was very conscious of his role a
fan of Philip Hammonds he will know that
he has quite a difficult task to keep
the economy in one piece and to restore
confidence and get some growth going
again but every Chancellor needs to put
his tin hat on with the flurry of
lobbying that hits every Chancellor
every year all sounds deeply deeply
moving do explore the facts and also big
problem for Philip choose what the
actual priorities are in the national
interest that's what you're there for
exactly as the governor's had to decide
what to do about interest rates in the
national interest